this was one of the big questions which
is sort of you know why do people who
claim to care so much about people of
color the poor the mentally ill the
people addicted to hard drugs why is it
that that the progressives have allowed
the situation to worsen so terribly in
california i debunk all the reasons
given people say we don't spend enough
money we spend more money than anybody
and i documented more money on mental
health than any other state worst
outcomes
people say it's because we don't have
enough permanent support of housing san
francis
san francisco
um san francisco uh has more permanent
support of housing per capita than any
other city and has the worst outcomes
you know what's going on here is that
this all boils down to victim ideology
where there's this idea that we can
categorize some people as victims
that nothing should be asked of victims
when you talk to your
liberal lefty friends or just like the
average california type person one of
the things that i'm still amazed now i
do sense a lot of people waking up and
you know i think that the election and
the way they treated larry was a red
pill for a lot of people but still
obviously the results were basically 70
30. so obviously out of the voters
they're they're down with newsome and
whatever that means
when you talk to some of the lefties
still
like do they think things are going well
here that always seems to be the
confusing part for me like who thinks
things are going well
i no i mean you know my most progressive
friends are the guys i play soccer with
and they don't think it's okay you know
they think it's a big problem
you know part of the reason i wrote san
francisco is because when i would raise
the problems with them including the
fact that the vast majority of people
living on the streets are addicted to
hard drugs or suffering mental illness
they would say to me um
it sounds like you just want to arrest
everybody and so i wrote san francico in
part to say here's what i want to do you
know here's what i think the plan is and
it's we don't have to choose between
mass homelessness and mass incarceration
there is a role for police there is a
role for laws and law enforcement but
that's not the end of the story and we
don't want to go back to one flow over
the cuckoo's nest but it's unacceptable
to have these you know hundred thousand
120 000 people living on the streets
using hard drugs a threat to themselves
and others totally unacceptable so no i
think that there's actually high levels
of
dissatisfaction i think we are looking
for
leadership whether that's coming from
the civil society level or from the
political level somebody's got to step
up and challenge newsome who obviously
is up for re-election next year so it's
kind of funny you wrote san francisco
obviously about san francisco you happen
to be in venice right now just visiting
i'm in la at the moment so we're only
about a half hour away from each other
and we wanted to do it in person but my
schedule's a little nuts today uh but
what's going on in venice because it
seems like venice has been completely
destroyed
yeah so you know what we call homeless
encampments is really a euphemism for
what european researchers call open drug
scenes so you know the san francisco
really describes the whole history of
how did we get here but basically we're
in the midst of two overlapping drug
epidemics as you know one the more
famous one is around opioids it started
with the over prescription of
opioids in the early to early late 90s
early 2000s we then uh curtailed doctor
prescriptions in the
you know around 2010 a lot of people
switched to heroin now a lot of people
are using fentanyl and dying 93 000
people died last year dave from illicit
drugs it's scandalous it's a moral
failing that's almost five times more
people that die from homicides in the
united states
about three times more than die from car
accidents up from 17 000 in the year
2000 so this is a moral crisis it's
disproportionately impacting california
homelessness increased in california 31
percent over the last 10 years while
declining 18 in the rest of the united
states
so what we're seeing in venice beach in
the tenderloin neighborhood of san
francisco in skid row in los angeles but
also in the blade neighborhood of
seattle
in portland where i just visited i was
just in portland but also in vancouver
and now we're seeing very similar
situations uh in philadelphia the
kensington neighborhood so these are all
best referred to as open drug scenes
that's i think the right way to think
about them that's the academic word but
you know there's only one way to deal
with them which is that you have to
require people to use shelter you can't
let people camp in public i know that
sounds like a radical idea but that's
not okay
um people if you wanna if there is some
role for providing people with housing
but they should earn it by making
progress on their personal plan towards
recovery from addiction or or taking
control of their psychiatric illnesses
but we need a shelter first policy we
need a treatment first policy the
housing first policy we have has
completely failed
it's basically unethical because it
doesn't actually try to deal with the
root of the problem which is addiction
everything that we do in california is a
band-aid solution so the solution to
venice speech was just to try to put
people in some hotel rooms temporarily
but everybody just ends right back out
on venice beach or in tenderloin or skid
row because we're not willing to deal
with the fundamental problem which is an
addiction crisis right so that's
actually one of the themes of the book
that the progressive and all the cities
you just mentioned are all progressive
cities that they sort of say the right
thing oh we'll put them in hotels they
will be off the street it sort of sounds
right but then you realize that now
they're just doing drugs in hotels and
no one suddenly gets a job or gets their
life in order is that sort of the
biggest theme to
maybe even a little bit of your own
political evolution that progressives
are constantly saying what sounds right
and easy oh we're not going to police
we're not going to worry about drugs
we're not going to do anything at home
so it all sounds like oh we're trying to
be nice to people but the end result is
pretty much everything in your book
yeah i mean this was one of the big
questions which is sort of you know why
do people who claim to care so much
about people of color the poor the
mentally ill the people addicted to hard
drugs why is it that that the
progressives have allowed the situation
to worsen so terribly in california i
debunk all the reasons given people say
we don't spend enough money we spend
more money than anybody and i documented
more money on mental health than any
other state worst outcomes
people say it's because we don't have
enough permanent support of housing san
francis
san francis
san francisco it's hard to not get to
the title um san francisco uh has more
permanent supportive housing per capita
than any other city and has the worst
outcomes
you know what's going on here is that
this all boils down to victim ideology
where there's this idea that we can
categorize some people as victims
that nothing should be asked of victims
everything should be given
including
you know the right to camp in public to
use drugs in public defecate in public
engage in even violent behaviors with no
consequences
it's um it's specific to the west coast
it's specific to progressive cities
um but it is spreading around the
country and so yeah i mean there's been
various i mean one of the funniest
things i interviewed progressives i
interviewed a lot of progressives for
this book by the way so they're all in
here and i i have my own you know i
worked for maxine waters to advocate for
needle exchange in the early in the late
90s i worked for george soros's uh think
tanks um in the late 90s so i and i
still support
you have a progressive pedigree there's
no doubt about it yeah um so they all
talk to me you know everybody talked to
me
and you know a lot of them it was like
they would say things to me like well
this really started with reagan you know
and i was like really like how so you
know
they would say reagan let everybody out
of mental institutions
as governor in truth it was actually
kennedy who got de-institutionalization
started
reagan
didn't do what he needed to do but it's
hard to blame it on him people claim
that reagan cut the budget for housing
really the budget for housing at the
federal level stayed the same when he
was president it declined very small
amounts mostly the changes had nothing
to do with him
progressives have been in charge as you
know in california for a really long
time so this is not a problem that they
can put
on anybody else's back this is really
something they have to own and in fact
you know gavin newsom who used to
identify or position himself anyway as a
moderate democrat
was the person who advocated the housing
first policies in 2005.
by the way it was george w bush who
instinct who is who made that official
federal policy so it's really been a
bipartisan policy to some extent but the
idea that you should just give people
housing with no requirements on behavior
change has been a progressive you know
i've been at the top of the progressive
agenda for 20 years if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell